what's happening there reject nation we
are of course going to check out from
new rockstars today the easter eggs a
breakdown for the trailer for miss
marvel a show that every individual is
equally looking forward to mind you go
on social media you'll find out anyhow
if you guys leave a like that'd be very
much appreciated swing action please
subscribe to new rockstars if you
haven't done so already
[Music]
welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of the
trailer for miss marvel introducing
kamala khan as the new mcu hero taken
directly from my high school years
another adventure shirt cute not today
mavisto i am really digging the vibes of
this series and its trailer is filled
with subtle clues for what could really
be going on here so i'm gonna break it
all down frame by frame let's go
[Music]
i do love that text okay so first off i
just want to say
i get it
you get what we open with kamala's diary
which she doodles this pig flying into
space as she wishes she could be among
the stars and one day will be this might
actually be her stuffed animal that we
see later on her bed coming from a
devout muslim family she's not supposed
to eat pork but as we saw in the comics
she still loves to smell bacon calling
it delicious delicious infidel
meat captain marvel comics kamala khan
shortly after got her own solo series in
2014 where we saw a terrigen mist bomb
enveloped her and caused her to envision
her heroes captain marvel iron man and
captain america and she emerged from
that cocoon emulating the appearance of
her hero carol danvers but with the
powers to embig in her limbs until she
realized she could just be herself and
maintain that stretchy ability in her
own form and appearance now pterogenesis
is actually the process by which
inhumans are
formed as we saw with quake in agents of
shield but the mcu version of kamala
khan might be going in a different
direction more on that later also you'll
notice among our doodles is ant-man
versus man ant with scott lang having
some fleshy human limbs on that side oh
god
crossover i feel like we're kind of
gearing up for ant-man to make an
appearance in one of these marvel tv
shows if you look at hawkeye when they
had a clear reference and they got the
the arrow is a pin particle thing so
yeah there's a direct reference
especially totally seeing the kind of
tone that this show is striking kind of
cool if we got ant-man to make an
appearance in one of these oh absolutely
also if we got something like man ant in
here we've all wanted i don't know about
all of us but a lot of us have wanted
that human spider thingy man
it's always just reverse it man batman
spider man and we got man in here i
think we win over all the haters there's
also a note for driving lesson today an
essay due on the 19th scratch that the
16th oh and a reminder to include
references and quotes and a drawing of
herself calling this all boring i also
like the little glimpse of kamala's
fashion with her index finger now
painted a different color then we move
past a world history textbook showing
ancient egypt on the cover a corner of
the world that will be explored even
sooner right moon knight and then we
glide into kamala's fantasy escapism in
the form of her drawings the marvel
studios title card within her comic book
sketched out thought bubble and then the
frame itself condenses into a hand-drawn
version of that depicting how kamala
sees her whole world through the filter
of her own imagination this does feel
very spider-man homecoming reminiscent
especially with the kind of aesthetic
that it has here the type of animation
to with its logos and whatnot even right
down to kamala khan her fantasizing
about being out of school and doing
something actually exciting that is a
super heroic sense versus boring school
like her interests are just not in
academics right now and she wants to do
something larger than life so a lot of
this feels very much connected to what
they actually did tonal stylistic-wise
with spider-man homecoming now covering
footage with animated sound effect words
action lines word bubbles which you'll
know to spill out from beyond that frame
is the kind of aesthetic that we saw in
scott pilgrim versus the world and it's
spider-man into the spider-verse and now
to see it in the mcu like this is a
really vibrant choice that not only
takes us inside kamala's mind but hints
at the way her physical powers are
actually manifested from her wish
fulfillment like wanda master that's
kind of interesting
yeah someone else's physical reality now
kamala's guidance counselor is mr wilson
his name is likely a nod to g willow
wilson who wrote these miss marvel
comics and is also represented in that
desk divider being labeled gw if it is a
reference to her
where's all the outlines make him a man
huh yeah there's the outrage messed up
we can't reference women writers too
woke how am i supposed to enjoy my
fandom material if it's not associated
with some outrage you're already asking
me to identify with the girl his office
is filled with motivational posters like
that classic hang in there kitty and
then on the door you can totally do this
he's also got tissues on his desk for
students who come in crying or leave
crying he says or if he wants to touch
himself
couldn't be a pretty stressful blow your
nose
but the way kamala writes her lowercase
g's in her word bubbles it's just
interesting circles connected by a
straight line i don't know i've never
seen g's written this way but i also
don't know how those gen zeros are doing
it these days but to me this at least
looks like the middle portion of the pym
technologies
could just be another example of how
kamala is really an ant-man as we saw in
her diary and specifically someone's
gotta be enabled ability to imbibin i
say it's it's true i agree i agree okay
we get this really cool shot of the
clock rotating counterclockwise as we
anchor on the minute hand flying through
the day much like peter parker in the
opening sequence of spider-man
homecoming kamala khan just spends her
whole school day staring at the clock
waiting for it to end behind her is a
poster reading vote dusted for prez he's
a very good choice justin berry was
actually the set decorators slash set
buyer
series along with ant-man and another
ant-man story movie civil war but look
at you you made yourself so much anna
dustin berry you go dustin berry the
girl
deliberately mispronounces kamala and
this is her shirt zoe is actually from
the miss marvel comics popular girl whom
kamala ends up saving from the hudson
river and the two become really good
friends especially with zoe even
developing a crush on kamala's
turkish-american friend
seen here alongside bruno corelli
ladies let's get informational mission
off with captain marvel and wasp and
valkyrie all wearing glasses of course a
play on olivia newton john's let's get
physical i assume inspired by these or
let's get information beyonce
and uh yeah evangeline lilly based on
your recent comments let's definitely
get informational yeah isn't the common
belief that it's what you said i thought
that's the common thing let's get in
formation yeah from the formation song
yeah from beyonce yeah i feel like it
cuts in both ways but i think it's
beyonce first five feet the kids are
here for queen bee at least on social
media that's what everyone was saying
yeah that is get more in touch with
twitter to twitter
come on let's see zoey with devil horns
and i just gotta say between this and
the devil horns in no way home at this
point it honestly feels like marvel
studios is just mephisto trolling me to
which i would say he saves you he sees
all in the circle q store kamala and
bruno stand beside this captain marvel
cosplay outfit with a looks like a paper
mache mask i think kamala made this now
bruno actually works at this location in
the comics kamala uses it as her
unofficial headquarters then at a party
kamala does some true scott pilgrim
ogling at cameron who looks like he just
hopped out of that pool despite everyone
else wearing outerwear maybe the guy got
pushed in or jumped in on a dare or just
thirst trapping all these girls yeah
euphoria was actually hit with that same
terrigen mist that gave kamala her
powers causing cameron to develop an
ability where he emits a bluish energy
from his body and then channels
electrical energy into objects that
caused him to glow and explode he was
later recruited by the villain lineage
framing him here with that blue tinted
steam over the pool could be a nod to
his terrigen origins and his powers oh
neato i love it into this beautiful bun
and as they stare at cameron notice poor
bruno off to the side clearly feeling
inadequate no one talks about bruno
don't worry kid you got a bright future
heavy and making youtube videos for some
lin-manuel tracks to make the viewers
cringe also why am i advising a
fictional character next clip
but you're staring at the window in your
little fantasy land
[Applause]
oh fantasyland already really come on
like you i have to figure out my whole
future before launchers it's really like
okay we get this great euphoria style
shots yeah you bore it
that's what disney wants to reference
for sure around her right as we hear the
weeknd's blinding lights her head is
totally casting a shadow on that screen
by the way this is actually the same
kind of lighting and being used in one
division to introduce that skrull who
introduced monica rambo in the movie
theater projector light and i do think
we will see some skrulls appear in this
miss marvel series to set up the secret
invasion series then the frame cuts back
on inner frame of kamala's imagination
showing her fantasies suited up in the
captain marvel outfit but the one from
the beginning of end game the red on top
not the blue topped one that carol
changed into in the final battle and
wore in that chunk chief post-credits
scene
when does miss marvel take place captain
marvel who saved iron man and she
strikes a classic black widow superhero
pose nice another fantasy shows are
suited up but wearing tiara and carrying
roses like the homecoming queen and then
a shot of cameron on his car with roses
flower petals raining down from nowhere
this is like kamala's american beauty
fantasy and i feel just as uncomfortable
looking at it let's move on let's get
some plastic bag footage kamala and
bruno sit on the roof of this building
that neon sign from the other side
actually reads madison that first letter
is an m there but beneath their feet is
a poster or a painting that i think
reads iron man there so like peter
parker's world she's just surrounded by
iconography of iron man and reminders
how he's dead and again with the steam
there's just lots of mist in this
trailer for a story that seemingly won't
use terrigen mist to give kamalakon her
powers who knows terence and miss may be
behind all of this i mean we don't know
for sure if terrorist and miss will
factor into this show or not i mean
there's this whole deal that's just
happened right now where like the all
these shows are officially gonna be on
disney plus it would seem that they're
making these shows officially mcu cannon
i think with the amount of changing of
powers that they've done so far in
including terrorism missed in some way i
mean if they've done an agent of shield
already haven't seen in humans i'm going
to assume they did it in inhumans if
they did shield already like you pointed
out then i feel like there's got to be a
way to bring it in here consider that is
the origin of her in the comic books
well yeah it makes me wonder if you know
they've done a lot to separate agents of
shield and humans certainly from the
main mcu and that all works in a
multiverse and maybe this could be the
opportunity to introduce something like
that to this iteration of the timeline
or something maybe something to do with
the bracelet has terrigen crystals
inside or maybe it's a completely
different thing but like it would be a
neat thing to bring back in and
incorporate especially with you know
x-men and other things on the horizon
you know get your variety of different
origins going we see some shots of
kamala and her family praying at their
mosque and then kamala and bruno at this
display of a sparkly captain marvel
costume the signs in her badge necklace
read new jersey avengers looks like some
kind of expo or convention which might
be like that a day celebration in the
avengers game that kamala attends in san
francisco where a terrorist attack
overloads a terrigen energy crystal
powering that telecarrier that ends up
releasing a mist that ends up giving
kamala her powers you'll notice kamala
also wears a captain marvel patch on her
jacket the later shot of her on her bike
shows this is a green canvas jacket much
like carol danvers flight suit and it
even has that same air force test pilot
patch on the sleeve kamala's mother
moniba khan criticizes her costume that
may lead kamala to define her parents to
attend that convention it looks like she
drew it with a marker really how she
gets in all that trouble moving on it's
not really the brown girls from jersey
city
you save the world
that's a fantasy too
okay interesting shots here of kamala's
snooping around an attic with a
flashlight where she finds his chest
filled with files and in which she finds
these bracelets these glow when kamala
snaps them on and you'll notice they
have this star burst icon on the cuff
similar to the astral iconography of the
cree that captain marvel emulates as her
logo yeah in the reaction i wondered if
these could be the nega bands from the
captain marvel comics given to captain
marvel by the crease supreme
intelligence that ends up really
trapping captain marvel in the negative
zone should be a really cool way to
bring in the fantastic four potential
but i also want to see that but based on
the powers they give kamala khan they
could also be quasars quantum bands
which have similar that's what i'm
saying
powers i'll just say that the design on
the cuffs suggests that these come from
some kind of alien race extraterrestrial
origin personally i'm getting more cree
vibes i'm thinking that it probably
wouldn't be more likely if between the
two theories that it would be cree
considering the fact that this trailer
especially is going out obviously to
really show that this miss marvel is a
major fan of captain marvel considering
her comic origins if they wanted her to
be along the lines of like yeah an
obsession with captain marvel honoring
that it would make more sense to get it
from some type of cree ability she will
be in the movie the marvels as well so
line up i think it's more likely you
could just introduce some kind of
conflict too where like yeah if there is
something sinister about them maybe it's
that thing of oh my powers persist
without the bands you know we don't know
whose attic this is or why kamala came
up here but nearby are some lab coats
and some lab equipment and a few doll
house miniatures one could tank
pennsylvania
who has a history of shrinking down
buildings to miniature size or even with
howard stark who had a miniature stark
expo in his home but my theory is that
this attic could belong to someone in
kamala's community who might be revealed
as a scroll in hiding remember the
scroll changes posing as nick fury and
spider-man far from home hinted at a
skrull cree shadow war currently being
waged i thought cree having sleeper
cells was top secret information these
bracelets could have been creed weapons
of mass destruction stolen and hidden by
a skrull on earth and then accidentally
discovered by kamala thinking they were
just cool additions to her cosplay but
then they accidentally power her up into
a creed powered superhero like her hero
captain marvel which would be what draws
kamala into the cree squirrel conflict
that monica rambo is now joining the
scroll faction of based off that one
division post-credits scene which would
explain how all these three come
together in the marvels next year yeah
see
you're right
when kamala first powers up and her eyes
glow purple right behind her is a statue
of rocket raccoon from that adventure
just a little oh cool
earthbound story we are dealing with
truly cosmic implications here what if
her powers kind of coincide with the
nega bands and terrorism myths like some
type of activation occurs via through
that like there's common theories of
perhaps the celestial's radiation or
thanos's snap that might activate the
mutation gene that people carry so what
if there's something similar with her
where we actually find out down the road
that she could be i don't know mom was a
mutant but yeah that she had that gene
activated and thus just has the power
now due to that yeah and not for the
lasting you know connection to whatever
bands she's got otherwise that is just
green lantern without the rape
and when she falls backwards she passes
some other cosplayers you can see an
iron man two different captain america
shields and then the november footage
actually showed a nebula here then she
falls through the floor into a kind of
sunken place it looks like but she ends
up right side up surrounded by a new
crowd of figures who are these people
are they just a mere reflection of the
cosplayers or are they someone else the
upside down
the supreme intelligence takes a
different form to whomever sees it and
carol danvers infusion through the cree
tahiti process left her with false
memories so if these bracelets these
cuffs are cree tech kamala in this
moment could be mentally projected into
the memories of the kree warrior who
last wore these these others in this
purpley realm could be past cree on the
planet
and then kamala could come out of that
state with those kree powers manifesting
her own inner desires the way the
creased supreme intelligence in a way
reflects something you deeply that's
masturbation
energy waves definitely match the
visuals we saw for carol danvers power
up and monica rambo passing through that
radiation wall of west view to become
boton all three women empowered with the
same kind of cosmic radiation okay
kamala sitting at the table envisioned
some light pouring into her home they
were kind of marvelous and more mist i'm
not sure if this is literal terrigen
missed or just missed in her mind but
missed her brother amir stephen
her room is actually filled with captain
marvel posters by the door more art of
that pig now a unicorn actually over
kamala's bed is a poster of captain
marvel showing a specific comic this is
jerry dodson's cover of earth's
mightiest hero number five then we see
this we have a 3d model of that right
back i mean oh no and then kamala looks
like her glowing hands in this place
with green walls and weapons in a case i
think this actually might be part of a
trip kamala takes to visit relatives in
pakistan which would be where she meets
the vigilante red dagger kareem all part
of a process perhaps to train kamala to
be more of a hero kamala says her powers
appeal to cosmic another indicator that
they're coming from the same cosmic
radiation source as monica rambo and
carol danvers powers and we see what
those look and they look like the
multiverses
she uses to close doors and then lily
pad through the air now again in the
comics she's supposed to be able to
stretch or embiggen her limbs but
actually if you look closely at her last
jump here her arms and legs are totally
stretchy this isn't like a green lantern
energy covering her limbs it's inside of
her stretching her body out oh
cool okay the trailer only hints at this
shady group of people in black suvs i'm
wondering if they could be part of some
enforcement agency like the dod hawkins
left
do some experiments for humans
throughout society we see another misty
shot in an alley with these four mystery
figures there's a woman a man another
woman and another man now i wonder if
this group can actually be those cree
sleeper cell agents coming back to
reclaim the cuffs or maybe some skrull
agents coming to recruit her but
actually you can see that woman on the
far left appearing in the background
behind kamala in the wedding venue so
this group is going to be an ongoing
threat that goes after the khan family
in the middle of a relative's wedding
and then more shots showing kamala's
visit to pakistan a procession of people
passed a large fire and the kamala
enters that green building that we saw
earlier following this woman who later
asks if she knows what she is this woman
according to closed caption is named
najma that could be the older relative
who shelters kareem and knows more about
those cuffs not ajax
red dagger kareem
or maybe just spar in this pakistani
train station notice the urdu on the
sign there her giant fist smashes into
that dream stand and then cut into a
different scene where kamala retracts
the giant fist this is at the wedding
we're right after this we can see her
dancing alongside bruno bruno moving in
bruno playing a pretty big role here
helping a wounded cameron down the
subway car as they both flee men in dark
suits you can barely see in the car
behind so cameron will also play a
bigger role in this plot and simply
being the hunky boy kamala is into he
could be a new human like he becomes the
comics or maybe a skrull or a fellow
inhuman that kamala must protect from
that enforcement agency then maybe he's
her damsel in destroying my colorful
shock wave released by kamala she
smashes another car and again you can
see her limbs stretched she is totally
gonna be a shape-shifter in this series
it makes me happy that she's actually
shape-shifting internally yeah yeah the
trailers i couldn't tell if it was a
little bit confusing to me at the time
it did look very green-like it looked
like purely green lantern yeah with so
many people commenting on that to dive
in and see that yeah like there is that
energy coding but it does like actually
in bigoting herself is pretty sweet
armored soldiers charge down a school
hallway and then kamala forms a shield
to protect cameron from gunfire in the
background are some school buses
suggesting this is going down outside
that school it's just so scary to see
that shield breaking apart from some of
the bullets showing how kamala is not
yet mastering her powers she still is in
a lot of danger she's gonna get shot to
death okay after the title our final
shot shows kamala sitting on that street
light looking out at manhattan perfectly
recreating of the cover of miss marvel
number five but i just love how this
compares to that earlier shot of her
with her bike staring out of the city
with a sense of longing to be part of
something bigger but now even after
becoming a true superhero she doesn't
leave jersey city for manhattan she
stays this is still her home she's just
looking at the city from a higher
vantage point like more of a guardian
protecting her turf from any threats
from the big bad guardian of nj folks i
am super excited for this series and of
course new rockstars is definitely going
to be covering it when it drops on june
8th so be sure to subscribe for my
birthday all of our marvel content you
can follow me on instagram and twitter
at ea boss you can follow me rockstars
of course thank you so much for watching
and bye bye
dope
loved fun and very endearing thanks mr
voss you rocked our socks off mr boss
boss gonna be mephisto someday you'll
see when you're least expecting it
in midnight suns guys thank you so much
for being here subscribe to rockstars
leave a like last but not least
rosa parra reason why i wanted to shout
you out rosa is because you know who we
should really be marveling at in this
world hard working
critics critics that's right so many
movies so many critics out there and not
enough in the latin community and you
were holding it down this show deals so
much with family children being a mother
and i gotta say
that you cover as a critic so many
movies about families and there's really
nothing else that i could think of in
your personal life that would identify
with such a purpose i think what you got
going on is really strong and probably
the most important thing in your life as
you can see in this trailer too like
kamala is just trying to like find a way
to be something more while kind of
losing sight of her family along the way
and so with that in mind thinking about
you and how you have a family is that
one day your kids will be critics that's
right and they will be great reviewers
and they will outperform you rosa
tomatoes this is called subverting
subversion
[Music]